"Не боїмося. Скільки Господь назначив, стільки і будемо"
"Не боюсь. Що Богу вгодно!"
"Значит, судьба такая!"
Поки одні українці довіряють вищим силам чи б'ють поклони на мітингах проти щеплень, інші все ж покладаються на вакцину.
При цьому і одні, й інші можуть бути ревними вірянами.Чому ж так складається?
Церква, волонтери і армія - на перших позиціях в рейтингу довіри українців уже багато років.
Втім, як засвідчила нинішня пандемія коронавірусу, в кризових ситуаціях ця довіра
може нести різні наслідки для людей.
Соціолог Максим Паращевін досліджував, як віряни різних конфесій сприймають події, пов’язані з коронавірусом,
у рамках масштабного опитування громадян України щодо наслідків пандемії.
Науковець стверджує, що вплив церкви, хоч і не визначальний, але все ж є.
Як і за іншими багатьма показниками, найкраще себе проявляють прихильники УГКЦ.
У них більші показники скорочення користування транспорту, скорочення контакту з іншими людьми,
зменшення відвідування місць скупчень, намагання дотримуватися дистанції, носіння масок, збільшення миття рук і готовності робити щеплення.
А УПЦ вони лідирують, у них більші показники за небажанням робити щеплення.
Також, за даними соціолога, віряни Української православної церкви Московського патріархату,
так само як і позацерковні православні, частіше оцінювали коронавірус як штучну кризу з навмисним поширенням для чиєїсь користі.
Водночас дослідження соціолога показало, що всі віряни, незалежно від релігії чи конфесії, висловлювали невисоку довіру до офіційної інформації.
Хоча всі конфесії свого часу опублікували заяву, що вакцинація - це медична справа,
а отже, церква не причетна до рішень щодо неї, меседжі і реальні кроки щодо щеплень різняться.
Так, наприклад, Українська греко-католицька церква надала дозвіл на відкриття
першого у країні пункту вакцинації у храмі, а саме - в Патріаршому соборі Воскресіння Христового у Києві.
Отець Тарас, який також займається комунікаціями УГКЦ, вважає, що
Церква не має відмежовуватись від проблем суспільства, зокрема, пандемії коронавірусу.
Незважаючи на те, що є різні думки, конкретні жести засвідчують про конкретну позицію однозначно.
Ніхто не примушує до вакцинації.  Ніхто не каже, що ти не пройдеш до храму і не підеш помолитися, поки не пройдеш пункт вакцинації.
Але створюється додаткова можливість, щоб провакцинуватися.
Тому це є допомога церкви у боротьбі зберегти людське здоров'я.
Люди у черзі на щеплення також схвально оцінюють крок Української греко-католицької церкви відкрити пункт вакцинації у соборі.
Чесно кажучи, спочатку ми були противниками вакцинації. Рахуємо, що держава мало провела для цього роз'яснювальної роботи для людей.
Ми побачили сюжет у новинах, що в церкві відкрилося, і якби більш тут благоприятна аура,
ми приїхали з Правого берега, і всім рекомендуємо.
Це круто, це дуже круто. Церква повинна змінювати свою функцію.
Це дуже добре, що релігійна організація розуміє всі наслідки і бере на себе цю відповідальність,
як розповсюджувати спосіб вакцинації, тобто вона розповсюджує саме вакцинацію.
По-перше, це є дуже близько, де я проживаю. По-друге, це дуже приємно, що церква долучилася до таких заходів.
Я надіюся, що тут буде більше і самих прихожан, і людей, які тут поруч проживають. Це є знаковим, і тут приємно посидіти, подивитися.
За прикладом УГКЦ пункти вакцинації відкрили ще два храми у Запоріжжі:
один - Православної церкви України, а інший - УПЦ Московського патріархату.
Працюватимуть вони по кілька годин один день на тиждень - у неділю.
Водночас соціологи вважають, що позиції Церков щодо щеплень впливають тільки на тих вірян, які ще мають сумніви.
Офіційні заяви від релігійних представників тоді можуть або поглибити ці сумніви, або спростувати їх.
Такої думки притримується і отець Тарас з Української греко-католицької церкви.
Кожен канал комунікації, він має свою аудиторію.
Якщо на каналі церкви зібрані віряни, вони будуть слухати, що говорять їхні пастирі.
Якщо пастирі будуть неоднозначні в позиціях, або не будуть взагалі озвучувати, або будуть натякати на антивакцинаторську позицію,
то вірні будуть прислухатися. Можливо, вони інших просто-напросто не чують.
Рада церков, до якої входять 16 церков і релігійних організацій та 1 міжцерковна організація
саме розробляє спільну заяву щодо протидії коронавірусу в Україні.
Представник Духовного управління мусульман України зазначив, що його релігійна організація
позитивно ставиться до вакцинації, а також додав, що в ісламі існує загальне правило:
можна робити все, що не шкодить людині та суспільству.
А представники Федерації єврейських громад та Іудейської громади руху отримали щеплення
разом з іншими лідерами, аби популяризувати вакцинацію проти коронавірусу.
Українська православна церква Московського патріархату по-іншому бачить ситуацію з пандемією і вакцинацією.
Хоч офіційно також виголошують, що щеплення від “ковіду” - це особиста справа кожного християнина,
іноді від представників УПЦ МП можна почути суперечливі меседжі.
У 2020 році намісник Почаївської лаври, наприклад, підтримував конспіролгічну теорію про те, що Білл Гейтс нібито використовує вакцину, щоб чіпувати людей.
Після початку масової вакцинації у лютому 2021 Центр інформації УПЦ, опублікував заяву,
де посилаючись на своїх вірян, заявив, що вони не хочуть бути піддослідними тваринами і проти обов'язкових щеплень.
А у жовтні цього року антивакцинаторську акцію під стінами Верховної Ради очолював священник УПЦ МП з Почаєва.
Попри численні обіцянки пояснити свою позицію для DW, до виходу сюжету
представники Української православної церкви Московського патріархату так і не надали коментар у жодній формі.
Православна церква України, а також Українська православна церква Київського Патріархату публічно підтримали вакцинування, але не примусове.
Питання вакцинації як медичної процедури не є релігійним питанням, воно не наближає людину до Бога, і не віддаляє її.
Ми не підтримуємо примус, ми за те, щоб вакцинація була якісною, добровільною, ефективною.
І ми за те, щоб доносили до суспільства важливість вакцинації.
Директор Харківського інституту соціальних досліджень у 2020 році також аналізував настрої громадян України щодо коронавірусу.
Він, звертає увагу на особливу роль конкретних посередників між Богом і людьми, коли йдеться про те, щоб переконати чи відмовити вірян від щеплень.
Не в кожному приході є такий сумлінний пастор, який залучає своїх вірян до вакцинування,
деякі кажуть “давайте перечекаємо”, і так як довіра дуже висока, то це може утримувати людей від вакцинації.
Знайти антивакцинатора в рясі можна майже на кожній акції противників щеплень...
Те, що вони прищеплюють вас. Не відповідають нашим законам України про ГМО продукти. А це ГМО продукт являється. Ні маркування, нічого немає.
Таким чином навіть попри підтримку на офіційному рівні, будь-які сумніви від окремих представників
такого сильного авторитета як Церква можуть зневірювати прихожан у доцільності вакцинації.